hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel i hope you guys
are doing well today we will be taking
you through the express js full course
this express js full course is designed
in such a way that it will help you
understand the most widely used concepts
of express.js in an exciting manner
you will see how to create a simple rest
api in this video
by the end of this tutorial you will be
able to understand and deploy the
expressjs
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on
programming videos so if you are a
programmer and want to learn something
new then consider getting subscribed to
our youtube channel and press that bell
icon to never miss any update from
simply learn so let's go through the
agenda for this full course
first we'll see the introduction to this
course
after that we'll see what is express js
moving ahead
we will see how to install express js
after that we will see express js get
post method in detail
moving ahead we will see what is a
middleware and its function then we will
create a middleware in express.js
moving ahead we will see expressjs test
api and then
we will see react with express.js in
this we will also see how to connect the
server side to the client side
after that
we will see what is typescript and how
to connect node and expressjs
and in last we will be creating an user
registration form with express
so let's begin
i hope you guys are ready to learn
something new
now we will start our first topic
nodejs is a far javascript runtime
environment but it does not support
request handling functions http methods
or serving files
so expressjs comes into the picture
express makes the node.js code easier
as express provides a wide range of
features to develop both web and mobile
applications it is used to build single
page multi-page and hybrid page web
applications
as express is written in javascript it
is very easy to understand for the
developers who know javascript until now
express is the most popular framework of
node.js
you must have heard about main stack in
web development right
where e stands for express js
it is a backend part of mean stack
it manages routing http method sessions
error handling etc
let's see what express js is expressjs
is a node.js framework designed to build
apis web applications cross platform
mobile apps quickly and easily
it is very high performance
fast
lightweight and
that is there is no structural way to
write a code express does not force you
to write a code in a fixed manner
express.js is used as a server-side
scripting language
let's see the need for express js but
before that let me give you an example
if you have to write a rest api using
the core modules of node.js and the same
using the framework express js you will
realize that with the help of express it
will take 5 to 10 times less code and
time
that was the reason behind creating
express js framework for node.js
express.js is time efficient
fast money efficient very easy to learn
and asynchronous
let's see the features of express.js
for server-side development with the
features of node.js xps saves a lot of
time
middleware middleware is a request
handler that has access to the
application's request respond cycle
routing this refers to how an
application's endpoints urls respond to
client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
dynamic content on the web pages by
creating html templates on the server
debugging
express makes it easier as it identifies
the exact part where bugs are
let's see the advantages of express.js
express is unopenated and we can
customize it and use it as per our needs
as it is written in javascript a single
language is used for frontend and
backend development
express is fast to link it with
databases like mysql mongodb etc
let's see the disadvantages the
disadvantage of xpsjs is that there is
no structural way to organize things
sometimes the code becomes
non-understandable
there are so many issues with callbacks
the error messages that will come are
very challenging to understand
now we'll see the companies that are
using express.js
the major companies are ibm uber ebay
paypal accenture fox sports netflix
linkedin
as per the nlp.com there are more than
34 300 companies that are using express
js
now
i think you guys have a brief idea about
express as it is a lightweight framework
that gives functionalities to make
node.js easy
expressjs is trending so much because it
is helping so many developers to save
their time it is so awesome that most of
the companies are moving towards it
if you know javascript and node.js the
framework expresses what you should know
to strengthen your coding skills
now here
you'll find downloads
you can download node from here
and install it
but if you find any difficulties
downloading node.js you can click on the
link in the right corner to see how to
download node.js
now let's see the version for node to
verify here i am using visual studio
code you can go and search it and simply
download vs code
after opening your visual studio code
it will look like this
here
you will find a terminal click on it
the terminal window will open
here we will write node
hyphen b
this will show us the latest version of
node.js
now we need to update the npm which is
node packet manager this bundle consists
of all the repositories and packages
required for development purposes to do
that
npm install npm globally
nvm
install
npm
hyphen
globally
this will download all the npm packages
globally now let's create express
for that first we need to create a
separate folder where we will keep all
the modules and files of express js
let's clean this
tls
you can open the terminal by clicking on
the shortcut also by pressing control
and backtick
that will open the terminal for you
let's make a folder
mk dir
this is a command that is used to create
a folder on the terminal
then we will write our file name i will
write express
by
simply learn
enter
here you can see the file name expressed
by simply learn has been created
you can also click here
and enter your file name
m.js
press enter
as you can see a new file has been
created
now we need to install a package manager
that is npm
we will write a npm command
open your terminal again
write a command
in pm
init
enter
enter
version enter description and
description you can write express
tutorial
by
simply learn enter
enter
enter
hit repository if you have your git
repository you can add yours enter
enter
author
we learn
license enter
press yes
after this
you can see npm created a json file
now we will finally install express.js
we will write
npm
install
express
enter
now as you can see our express is
installed in our system
let's open the app.js that we have
created earlier
now
we will create a express application
with the help of express functions
that we can do
by requiring the express modules let's
create our first program
first
constant
express
required
express
in this line we are requiring the
express module
const
and name equals to
function
express
dot get
to get the file
request response
to get the request and the response
of the user
function
we will need to pass callback function
here
let's write
response send
this message
will be shown
in the server
welcome
to
welcome to simply learn
now here
we will write a port number where the
message will be shown to us
at dot lesson
4 000
you can write anything
here also
we are passing the callback function
console.log
in
log we will see the message in the
listening console port
number
4000
let's close this line
save this
let's run it open your terminal new
terminal
now to run this file
we need to go to the express
folder
cd
express
by simply learn
we are now in a simple learn folder
now
the easiest way is to write the file
name
write node
space
the file name app.js
enter
now
you can see it is printing our message
listening to port 4000
now we will see a message on the server
open your chrome
type
localhost 4000
press enter
and here we go a message is successfully
displayed welcome to simply learn
get in post method are the standard http
request used to create rest apis
get in post methods are used to send and
receive significant amount of data
the client sends a request in the form
of json file
and with the help of http requests which
are get post and other methods it will
go to the server and then the server
sends back the response to the client in
the form of a message to tell what
happened to the request that was sent to
the server
now
expressjs get method
get is a method that is used to request
data from the server but mainly this
method is used to read data
to handle get request in express is
pretty straightforward
get requests are to be cached and
remains in the browser history and
that's why the get method is not used
for sensitive data
to get the data we add parameters in the
url and get data in response
get method is more efficient and popular
than the post method
now we'll see express.js post method
host method is used to create new or to
edit already existing data
this method is used to communicate with
large amount of data
the post method is secure because the
data is passed in a request body and not
visible in the url and the user is not
able to bookmark it mostly
we use gate method only but when we want
to send a sensitive data we use post
method
now we will see how to get the post and
get methods work
now open your visual studio code
i have already installed node and
express if you haven't installed it then
you can click on the right corner of
this video to get the setup done coming
back to express get and post methods
now what i have done here is i have
created a basic express js app
const app require express this will
install all our express modules
now
first we will write our gate method
so let's start
first we will write get method
then we will initialize
how it will be called
will write get
this
question
we'll create
function request parameters
request and response
then we'll write the fat arrow function
in this
we will send a response
to the server
hello
this is
let's
i have not initialized the brackets
let's see what i have not done oh
forgot to write this
now let's just save this file
we will run this file open your terminal
and write node
dot
and
i think i have done something wrong
let's again open the terminal
write node
dot
so it is showing server is successfully
running on port 4000
now we'll open our chrome
and write localhost
enter
as i have told you earlier
this needs a parameter so we'll
initialize here
get
request
hello this is successful get request
so a request method is working fine
now
we'll go back to the post method and see
how it goes
app
dot post
request
response
response and
just like this only
just
post
hello
this is
successful
post
first
now we'll run save this first
and then run it in the terminal
yes
node
dot server is running on 4000
we have to write this
so first copy from here only
open your terminal
and here we can write
post quest enter
so what you can see here is it can't get
post request
for this to see
we need to have the
postman i'm using postman here
here i will write
post method
and here i will write the
localhost 4000 and the post request
method
then we'll press
send
here
in the body part
we will see hello this is successful
post request
how this is working is because post
method is secure and data is passed in
the request body and it cannot be
fetched in the url
what is middleware middleware is a
request handler that has access to the
application's request response cycle it
is a function that contains the request
objects response object and the next
middleware function middleware can also
send the response to the server before
the request
the next middleware function is commonly
donated by the variable named next
simply middleware is a function that can
only be applied using routers with the
help of middleware we can access and
modify request and response
now we will see what are the functions
of middleware
middleware can execute any code it can
make changes to the request response
objects
middleware can also end the request
response cycle
it can call the next middleware function
in the stack
we use these functions to modify our
middleware to perform many tasks
like if you want to block our site from
some country or if you want to check the
authentication of a user etc choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we are going to create a simple
middleware
we can create a metalware in a router
file but the best way is to create a
middleware file separately and then use
it
creating and using middleware is very
easy
now
we first need to create the basic
express application
but before that
you must have
all the app packages to run
express
you can take the help of our video what
is express.js the link will be in the
description
you need to install npm express to run
this so coming back to our application
first we need
construct express application
so we'll write constant
express
required
express
now
we'll write constant
app
equals to
express
function
now
to get the data we'll write app dot
get
request
just
response
function
write response send
welcome to
simpler
i will copy paste this
to get the
home page
the better way is to like
copy paste it
here
here we will write the extension of the
next page
home will say
and welcome to this villains
this is a very basic middleware
application we are going to create
this
home page
now we'll make it listen to some port
so we'll write
r
dot listen
control
log
write listening
this message will be prompting to us on
the console the terminal
so we'll close this brackets
now
we'll save this file
open your terminal
first we need to go to this folder city
express
by
turn
enter
now we'll write
file name
enter
so it's showing
listening to port 4000
now we'll open our chrome
local server
type local host 4000 enter
so it is successfully showing us welcome
to simply learn
now we'll go to the next page
we have written their
home
enter
so it's successfully showing
welcome to simply learns homepage
now
we'll create a middleware go back to
that
file
we'll write
stand
required filter
request
you can write anything here request
object
response object
and next
the fad arrow function
will write
console.log
we have right then request
this
app.use
request
filter
and save this file
now
we haven't
called our next parameter
in express framework next is a function
what we'll do is
we'll call it in the bottom of our
middleware
we'll write
next
option
save this file
again we'll open a new terminal
where we'll go to our folder express
by simply done
write node the file name dot here enter
now i'll open our file go to the
home
write
localhost 4000 enter
here it is printing welcome to simply
learn we'll go to the home page
welcome to simply learns homepage with
this we have successfully reached the
end of this video
npm
which is called as node package manager
is nodejs built in package manager by
default
and xpsjs is a framework of node.js
which is fully built in javascript
it was first made and available for use
in january 12 2010.
let's move on to what is npm
let's take async as an example npm is
incredibly easy to use and all you need
to do is to type npm install async to
install the desired module in the
current directory under node module
folder
you may use need function on them as
they use built-ins once installed in
your node modules folder
the biggest software registry in the
world is npm there are more than 80 lakh
code packages in the registry to share
software open source developers utilize
npm
npm is often used by businesses to
control private growth
all of the node.js packages and modules
are managed through npm which also
includes the npm command line client
along with the installation of node.js
it is added to the system npm is used to
install the necessary modules and
packages in the node project
moving ahead
let's see what is a package
in node.js a package includes every file
required for a module
you can add module in a javascript
libraries to your
project now
let's see the functions of node package
manager which is npm
online node.js packages modules
repositories can be searched on
nodejs.org
use a command line tool to manage
node.js packages dependencies version
control and installation
now let's see how to install npm
to install node package manager we have
to install node.js
for that
you have to download node.js and install
it in your system
now
we will see the version of node.js
go to terminal new terminal
and search here
for
node
hyphen v
which is denoted as version
enter
and this is my version of node
now
we will verify the npm version to do
that we have to run a command
write npm
hyphen hyphen
version
and you can clearly see
my npm version is 8.5.3
now
we will see how we can install node
modules using npm this is a very simple
syntax for that
we just have to write npm install and
that module name
now
we will install the famous web framework
module of nodejs we will simply write a
command
npm
install
express
this is a very simple command you can
write in your console or terminal
and then press enter
you can clearly see
the express is installed in our system
what is error handling
errand handling is a process in which
express catches and processes the error
that occurs synchronously and
asynchronously
express comes with its own default error
handlers
simply
in error handling the tasks are to
identify errors report them to the users
and then develop some recovery
strategies and implement them to handle
the errors
this whole process should not slow the
overall processing time of the program
now
how does error handling works in
express.js
expressjs comes in with a built-in error
handler
this default error handling middleware
function is added at the end of the
middleware function stack
it automatically catches all errors in
router handlers and allow developers to
extend router handling functionalities
by middleware function
error handling in express is done using
middleware
this middleware is defined in the same
way as other middleware functions the
error handling functions have four
arguments error request response and
next
we have next function method
that matches us to the next middleware
handler in middleware
in error handling we have the next error
method this function skips all
middleware and matches us to the next
error handler for the router
now let's set up our error handling with
express
open your visual studio code
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
first we will create a new directory
for that
open your terminal
new terminal
let's write
make directory
now i will enter the directory name
i will write
simply learn
or you can also write
error
press enter
you can see
the
link directory has been created
it's empty
let's go inside that
cd
see the error handling
now we are in the headline folder
now let's create a new project here
we'll write npm
in it
hash
y
so
as you can see
the json file has been created in the
error handling folder
now
we will install couple of packages here
okay
first we will install express
write npm
install
express
now we will also
install morgan
which locks the request
after that we'll also install http
errors
errors
this package makes it very easy to check
the status code
and then last
we will install node dot
enb
press enter
this will take couple of seconds
now in the dependencies you can see dot
env express http errors and morgan
now i will create a file in this error
handling folder
write
app.js enter
now
let's install nodebond which helps us
not to reset our file again and again
for that we'll write in the
npm
install
minus sign
save
node mode
enter
this will also take a couple of seconds
now
here you can see
the node 1 has been successfully
installed
now
open your package.json files
here
in packet.json file
you can see here
this line
i will rewrite this
you can also remove it let's write
script
and in this
i will write
note mon
tap
dot js
yes
save this file by pressing ctrl s
yes
now
open the file
app.js
here we will be importing some packages
in node.js
we use require function right
so
we'll write const
express
required
and
express
here we need express packages
now we will be needing morgan
we will write const
organ
required
then
now
like this we will need http packages
const
error
create
error
required
http
errors
we also need dot emv packages to import
our environment variables
for that we will simply write required
required
tactics
for this command we need a env file we
will create a file
dot
emb
printer
and here we have our env file where we
can have our environment variables
first we want a port for this
application so we will write the port
port
3000
save this file
now
again go back to the app.js file
here
first we will be initializing our app
we'll write const
tab
express function
now we will start the application for
this we will write
const
port
to which it will be called
process
dot emb
dot
port
3000.
now we will make our application listen
to port 3000 we will write
dot lesson
port number
port
it will call the port number
and here
we will call the callback function
better function
and here we will
make our blog statement
for this we'll write console
dot log
backtech
server
is
running
on
board
dollar sign
and
both
now
let me start the application before that
we'll save this file
now to start the application we'll write
npm
start
enter
here
it is showing error let's find out
okay
here
here i have wrote script
here we need to write start
save this file
and now clear this screen
enter npm
start
so as you can see it is successfully
running in the port 3000. rest api are
the standard way to send and receive
data for web services
client sends a request which goes to the
rest api
then to the database
to get or put the data
after that it will come back to the rest
api and then to the client
using an api is just like using a
website in a browser
but instead clicking on the buttons we
write code to request data from the
server
it is very flexible and can handle
multiple types of requests
restful api is very popular and very
commonly used to create apis for
web-based applications
what is express js
expressjs is a node.js framework
designed to build api's web applications
and cross-platform mobile applications
it is used as a server-side scripting
language
express js is high performance fast
lightweight and unopenated
we'll see what is rest api but before
that what is rest and what is api
rest means
representational state transfer
rest is a popular architecture which is
used to create web services
now
api is an application programming
interface it is a code that allows two
software programs to communicate with
each other
rest api is a software that allows two
applications to communicate with each
other with the help of internet and
various devices
now
we will see the http request types
first one is get
it is used to request data from the
server but mainly this method is used to
read data
next one is
it is used to update the data or to
change or replace it next is
post
post method is used to create new or to
edit already existing data
after that
it is delete
delete method is used to delete the data
completely from the server
now we will see the complete
architecture of http request type
in this
client sends a request in the form of
json
file and with the help of http request
which are get patch post and delete it
will go to the server
and then
sends back the response to the client in
the form of message
to tell what happened to the request
and now we will create a simple restful
api from scratch
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
first
you need to open your editor for this i
am using vs code
for this
you need to open your folder
created one folder in the
c drive
express js
for this
you need to have node.js installed
first
open your terminal by clicking on
terminal new terminal
first
we'll write npm
init
hyphen y
press enter
this will create a json
file plus
now let's install express.js
for that
we'll write npm
install
express
press enter
installing express js
this will add
all the dependencies
for now we have only one express
installed
we need a file here
to write our code
so we'll create a file called index
dot js
enter
in this file we will write all our code
open index.jsjs
first we'll write
cons
express
in this line we have imported the
express package
which itself is a function
so we'll write parentheses here
to initialize it
now
write
cons
out
writing 4 000 here
this will call a variable
which is 4000
i will write
dot lesson
till now our api hasn't defined any
endpoints
this app.listen tells the server to
listen on specific port
which we have defined already as a
variable
4000.
now
in app.listen
we will write a second argument as
callback to tell us the api is working
or not
then we'll write
port
comma
we'll write the callback function here
function
console
dot
log
backtick
it's
running
on
http
cap
which will come under curly braces
now we can run this app by writing the
command on a terminal
first save this file
terminal
now we'll write a command
to run this file
index
node
file name
index.js
so it's successfully showing us it's
running on http port
4000
open your
chrome or anything
i'm using chrome here i'll write
localhost
4000
enter
closed enter
can't get
now
if you open this url you will see
this message
can't get
this is because we don't have any api
endpoints as of now
but express js is still responsing with
error message
you can add an api and call it
every application consists of front-end
back-end and the database together they
form full stack and in this video we
will be talking about react and express
js
react was created by meta and it is used
to make web application responsive
express js is annotated and it is used
to make apis express is maintained
by node.js
let's see what is react.js
react is a javascript library which is
used to build mobile in web applications
fast and interactive
it is an open source
reusable components based front-end
library of javascript
basically with the help of react we can
create a client-side application or user
interface
it is a combination of html and
javascript
let's see the features of react.js
first jsx
it is syntax extension of javascript
with the help of react.js we can use the
extension to see how the ui should look
like
virtual document object model dom it
defines how document are exist and
manipulated in the web page
performance there are several ways to
speed up your exact application by using
virtual dom
one way data binding information flows
in one direction react receive
information through arguments and pass
it by returning values
react goes beyond simple ui and has many
extensions for complete application
support
extended with flux and redux among
others
debugging
it is a small browser extension to make
debugging easier and faster
let's see what is express.js
express is a node.js framework designed
to build apis web applications
cross-platform mobile apps quickly and
easy it is very high performance fast
lightweight and unopenated express.js is
used as a server-side scripting language
let's see the features of express js
first
fast server-side development with the
features of node.js express saves a lot
of time
middleware middleware is a request
handler that has access to the
application request response cycle
routing
this refers to how an applications
endpoint urls respond to client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
dynamic content on the web pages by
creating html templates on the server
debugging express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
now we'll see how to connect client side
to the server side
first we need to create a folder i have
created a folder named react express
let's see
go to your c file
here i have created react express folder
now
we will be using a text editor in this
video i will be using visual studio code
let's open it
then
we will add all the npm packages and
create a react application called client
open terminal
new terminal
let's write some command
npx
hit
react
app
client
enter
this will take some time
until then
just
wait yes so it's downloaded
now as you can see the client folder has
been created
with all the npm files
in this client folder you will see all
the npm files node modules
json file also
yeah
now
we'll go to this folder
cd client
now to get this application running type
npm
start
enter
this command will start and compile this
application
now
it has opened a web page localhost 3000
this is the first client side
application startup page
this will be now working as a client
now
let's create a backend application for
that first
clean this
terminal let's open a new terminal
type
npx
express
engine
data
folder name
press enter
okay
now
this will take some time to install
press yes why
as you can see api folder has been
created
now we'll go to that api folder cd
api
enter
now we are in the api folder
let's install
all the packages in pm
install
press
enter
this will again download all the
packages
so npm has installed all the packages
required to run this
as you can see in the packages.json file
there are all the repositories and files
that i used
now let's terminate this terminal
terminal
now let's go to the client folder
cd
client
press enter
now we are in the client folder
npm
this command will start and compile this
application
now
we'll see the standard express
application that has got installed
will again go to the terminal
delete this terminal
create a new terminal
and this
will go to the api folder
npm
start
will start the terminal
press enter
now we'll go to the chrome
localhost 3000
refresh it
you will see the standard express
application that has got it installed
what is typescript typescript is an
object-oriented programming language it
is a strongly typed superset of
javascript and all the code of type
script is compiled with javascript only
it is developed and maintained by
microsoft
typescript was created to develop
large applications
it is mainly used to simplify the
javascript code so that it can be read
and debug easily
what is nodej
nodejs is an open source cross-platform
javascript runtime environment
and it runs on a web application outside
the client browser
nodejs is used by the developers to
build server-side web applications
node.js is perfect for data intensive
applications since it uses an
asynchronous event-driven model
what is express.js
express.js is a node.js framework
designed to build apis web applications
cross-platform mobile apps quickly and
easily
expressjs is unopinionated
it is high performance fast lightweight
framework of node.js
expressjs makes the node.js code easy as
it is used as a server side scripting
language
now
we'll see how to setup node with express
and typescript open your visual studio
code
your folder which i have created in the
c drive typescript
it's an empty folder
i'll show you
open the terminal
i'll show you if it is empty ls
so the folder is empty
now we'll make a project inside it
we'll simply write npm
in it
hyphen y
for all the default values
press enter
so
you have seen
the package.json file has been installed
in this package
let's clear it
now the first thing you need to install
is typescript
type npm
d
this will install the typescript
dependencies
now i will install two more dependencies
please write npm
i
test
find node
i will also install nodemon
enter
this will install all the dependencies
there will be need in this project
let's clear the screen
now
now we have to install express
npm
install
express
let's wait for a couple of seconds
the npm express has been created
open the
package.json file here you see
all the dev dependencies
express
nodemon and ts node
has been successfully installed
now we need to create a project inside
this folder for that
we need to write npx
hyphen in it
wait for a couple of seconds here we go
here the screen
now will execute npx
psc typhoon
in it
so it has already been here
you can see
yeah
now we will be creating a source folder
for that
right mpdir
rc
enter
this would be containing all our
typescript files here
you can see
it's empty
let's create a file here
everything we're going to write is
inside this file only
so
you set up for typescript where the
express in node is ready
you can write anything
here
the first thing you need is node.js
let's see i have created one for me you
can create it by just entering a command
make directory in the terminal
and entering your folder name it can be
abc or something you need
and
like this
it will be created but i don't need it
so i'm going to delete
it in this
i will open the terminal again
i'll write a command
npm
in it
what
this will create a json file for us
like as you can see here
the json file has been created here
let's clear the screen
now
we will install express.js in this
folder
for that write a command npm
install
express
press enter this will install express.js
for us
you can also see here in the
dependencies
express has been successfully installed
and all other modules are here
so let's clear this screen now
now
we will create a server file here
let's name it app.js
here
we'll write all our code
so let's create a simple express folder
write
const
express
require
keyword
all over
modules will be here
in this we are requiring express js
now we will
also be needing
port
processes
dot env
dot
number that we'll gonna write here
using port number 3000 you can write
anything
this will be a port number now
express function
we have created an instance for express
now we'll create
make it listen to our port
let's write app
dot lesson
port number it will read by its own
header function
but we are going to see better
started at http
localhost
host
dollar sign
to get the data of the port
and write the port
it will fetch the number of the port
here it goes
now we have created a front end of this
i repeat now
we will create a front end of this
registration form so let's create it
first here
create a folder
public
in this folder
let's create two files
index
dot html
and
[Music]
second one will name as style.css
now
in the index folder
we'll write all our front-end code
so open
index.html page
write doc and enter
this will create a html template for you
in the title
here
we'll
write
registration
um
now
in the body part
we'll write
heading for this
h1
right heading
with this
right here the action will be class
heading so we can style it afterwards
using
now we'll create a form
fraction
class will be formed
now we'll create an input types
first we will create input
type will be
text
name
will be
write first name
first name
this folder
this username will become inside the
text box this first name
name
[Music]
now we'll create few more like this for
password
last name age number
let's copy this input
[Music]
first one will be first name second one
will be
last name
so we'll write the email
for this
password
placeholder
will write
it will be empty so no one will see our
password this will be
let's go to another one
and let's create a first name last name
email password and let's create one more
that will be uh
h
for this we have to write here
number
name we don't need name i
let's create a summit button
type of the button will
be submit
so we can
save it styling
yes
so our form is ready
uh yeah
we'll write require here
so
one
will be left empty
this will help us to
to require every field because
everything is important
we cannot
make it empty so we are writing required
so
our html page is ready
here
let's see how it looks
open this html page
here
a registration form look like this
let me show you what require is doing
as you can see please fill out this
field this is what required function do
submit
is
now coming back to vs code
we'll write some css code for styling
here we'll write
padding for the page
will be zero
we
don't have to write percent
margin
we'll also write zero for the overall
page
now we'll go to the
body part
so the height will be 100
ph
width will be
under the edge
this place size will be
legs
direction of the flakes will be
bottom
right justify content will be in center
alignment
item center
this is how we will
write a body part
coming to the
form of this page
bomb
right
everything will be a same we'll copy
this
let's paste it here
i don't want the height of the form
this much
it will be
that let's create it for
40
width will be 100 only
this place legs will be here
direction all this will be column only
justify contents
let's see
to our code
let's make it not center
let's make it as
space
you can style it as your own
as you want
heading
i think
display will be in line block
this will make our
page registration page look
more clean
perform
here
and put
what
i think we can do
10 questions from this
let's do something with the button
button
[Music]
it will be
padding will be
10 from this
and 25 from the other side
yes
okay
color for this
color will look like this
it's not an issue
using
the summit button
box
this will look cool
brown color
of the summit button will be black
and the text which is inside it will be
white so it looks clean
as a
registration form
it's
done can also
first save this file go to
file
a registration form look like this
isn't it cool
let's make this
a little up
the heading part will
a bedding for
40 percent
yeah it looks cool now
let's see everything is working fine
yeah
coming back to our vs code
now
so our front part is ready
if there will be any changes we'll do it
later
now coming back to our backend part
of this registration form
we'll make our first api routes
here
let's write
dot
get
on
request
response
that function
let's write here the response that the
form will send
we will write the directory name
of this html file
it's right here
name
public
x dot html
let's save it
coming back to our
also here
on post
and response
request
body
here in this part
it will fetch the data in the body of
the html page
now
let's create an api middleware
for that
used
stress
dot json
location
here we are accepting the data in json
format
after this we'll use it again
i've got use
express
dot url encoded
function
this
is basically to decode the data sent
through html form
static
starting function will be public folder
public
this will use the public folder for us
now
we'll save this file first
open your html file
and write in the form part
actions
here
will
declare the file name app.js
form
class form
and we'll write method
which will be
post here
everything looks
good before god to write inverted commas
here
save this file
now open the terminal
and write node
app.js
press enter
so our code is running fine let's open
it
yeah
everything looks fine
and with that we come to the end of this
full course tutorial if you enjoyed
watching the video do gives it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and our
experts will answer them for you
thank you so much for being here
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep folding and stay tuned to
simtila
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you